of the
david podcast today we have with us adam
sosnick and we have danielle de martino
booth
and we got a lot to cover you know it's
been a crazy last 48 hours we went to
sleep november 3rd
thinking trump's winning you woke up
everything flipped
and now biden's got a lead you said 85
percent chance that he's winning the
numbers that are coming from vegas so
daniel why don't you tell us what are
you thinking right
what's happened last 48 hours well hey
uh
you went to sleep tuesday night i feel
like i've been on ups and center since
friday nights
you did not sleep tuesday night this is
the well i i've slept for a few hours
but very difficult because they were
calling into the night
um and the wisconsin call was kind of
the next
big but the moment was arizona that was
the absolute moment
uh you know they've interviewed the guy
at fox news who made the call
uh their stories out on the wires that
give a you know vast description of what
the reaction was like
in the white house yesterday the phone
calls being made to the governor of
arizona
uh you know just complete and total
shock
because he took maricopa county in 2016
where phoenix is and because that's
where the vast majority of the
the votes have yet to be counted so it's
that arizona
that is really dividing the media right
now that is the focus that being said
if you look again at vegas odds and
those obviously the polls are garbage
so if you look at vegas odds you know
you've got
71 percent going for arizona even as we
continue to tally in
more votes more importantly you've got
pennsylvania at eighty percent
you've got georgia uh at uh
what do you mean eighty percent total
accounted you're saying just total
counted
no no no no this is vegas probability of
winning
got it of winning 80 is for who in
georgia
um and in georgia it is at 60
60 percent yep 60 percent enjoy
you're saying biden is up in georgia 60
in georgia probability wise vegas and
yep
so georgia he's got a 60 chance of
winning pennsylvania he's got an 85
percent chance of winning
arizona he's got a 71 chance of winning
they think nevada is a shoe-in
so theoretically you know the time we
get to the first announcement we were
expecting an announcement out of nevada
last night
that those six electoral votes will get
him over the 270 line
at least as far as fox news and the
associated press are concerned
so that is uh that is the first one that
we're waiting for for this morning
unless we get pennsylvania
pennsylvania is the only one that's a
little bit if here because there is the
potential to take
pennsylvania because of a recent ruling
to the supreme court
same situation does not apply in the
other states pat i mean let's talk about
where we've been for the last 24 or so
hours we did an amazing podcast a
marathon podcast
seven hours strong pat went to the
bathroom zero times
i'm i'm like i'm more proud of that than
anything then i went probably 12 15
times
you might want to visit a you know
that's a problem
and i would not go first that was our
friend tom center went first i was
holding up
he's he's getting we went seven hours
strong
right mats apollo was here respect to
matt ray crockett was here
obviously tom our friend jera we had a
surprise guest
tom ellsworth showed up he's geeking out
on some on some giggity giggities and
and and numbers and stuff and we had a
marathon
and what happened we all did a recap of
the night and we thought
going you know we left here two three in
the morning and we thought all right
trump's gonna be the guy again right and
we all kind of gave our sayings and i
even said
obviously it's been unashamedly i'm not
a trump fan i even said look i
if he wins again i hope that he can
bring this country together
yeah i actually went to bed that night
um
sang all right like what am i thankful
for if trump's the president all good
but like
i control my own destiny what am i
thankful for got my health i got my
wealth i got my friends i got my family
i got success
let me you know let me be thankful and i
woke up yesterday morning as we all did
24 hours ago or so and i was like hold
on what
by himself now it flipped so crazily
adam i mean
you remember in 2016 it was the florida
moment
and once we and it was the new york
times calling florida
four years ago but but once we saw
florida
once we saw florida go to trump it's
like okay i've seen this movie before
i know what the ending is and it was
that florida element and there had been
such
that was the tightest race and then
florida was called
earlier than we had expected and again
it's not just the cuban expat community
but as we'd spoken of
and after one of the debates there are a
lot of venezuelans there as well
you know you mentioned the word
socialist and they go they go crazy so
you know that was uh you know that was
maybe to be expected i watched em
they called texas after florida right
for heaven's sake
pat give us your recap we left here two
three in the morning yeah that was
tuesday night
we're now thursday we're 48 hours later
or so give us your recap where you at
emotionally
mentally you're exhausted i mean you
have to realize everything here is when
you run a business you got a family
you're going through a lot of different
positions you look at it from a
different
perspective but the one part you have to
realize is
you have to give credit to democrats you
just have to give credit to democrats
and what i mean by democrats is the fact
that these guys
even though many of them cannot stand
each other i had a guy yesterday who was
a former antifa guy
uh uh at 2011 2012 he was part of antifa
and he left okay he was a far left
liberal and then all of a sudden he
changes
young guy he's not 27 years old so 2012
he was what
19 years old 18 years old and he's
talking about a kid he's a kid but at
the same time he's talking about the
systems
how they recruit it i said so tell me
about antifa he says look
i said who's antifa's hero okay
check vera you know
i said who else is their hero today i
said do they look who's their enemy
yeah and i'm waiting when i say enemy
for him to say what trump trump
he says no it's not trump i said who is
the enemy he says everything about the
american
idea is their enemy their enemy is
christopher columbus
so what do you mean christopher columbus
their their enemy he says is what
america was founded on i said so they
like aoc he says they hate aoc i said
i'm confused
so i said so what do you mean the aoc he
says the day
aoc came out with 103 trillion dollar
package for
the climate change they said this is a
capitalistic
uh uh what do you call a capitalistic uh
plan that she's uh
so even are they anarchists what are
they they are they're fully they want to
change
everything about america take you back
to what it was pre-christopher columbus
to make america great again to what that
was so
what am i saying with this part and i
said tell me about blm tell me about
this so we went through all this other
stuff and what their conversations was
like this kid
yeah who was a former antifa left on
november 3rd you know what he did in dc
he dressed up like antifa put the black
mask on
went with them to see what they're
saying and what they're talking the
antifa guys that he was one of them
just to kind of see what's going on
right he was like dude i was scared i
don't know what's going
on i just kind of got myself out there
to see what the language is like an
undercover agent
yeah exactly but but the the point what
do you say
the point i'm trying to make to you is
the following the point of what he did
see is in dc
he said it's crazy because the media was
supporting antifa
the antifa guys would say hey why are
you recording this why are you recording
this don't record it oh we're so sorry
we'll go this angle so the journalists
of a lot of these big publications
they were controlling the influence to
not show the bad things they were doing
anyways
the point i'm trying to make to you is
you go to sleep you wake up in the
morning and you see what's going on you
say okay
michigan michigan was done i mean you
you sat there and said 80
i mean this thing is uh 64 65
you're thinking it's over with and then
you wake up things flip democrats united
whether it's
aoc's camp the four horsemen you know
who i'm talking about
the squad whether it's them whether it's
sanders whether it's
uh the clintons whether it's the obamas
whether it's the
lincoln project where there's no
infighting they just said
listen guys we can't stand each other
sometimes we don't like each other screw
you they hell with you
but guess what the enemy of the state is
who trump we got to do whatever we can
to put him out
now the numbers you got to see which is
pretty impressive is the following
in in 2000 when mccain ran when mccain
ran
he got four percent of latino vote when
mccain ran he run for he got
that's all he got that's all he got by
the way romney got six percent
okay uh black vote mccain got four
percent of black vote romney got six
percent the black vote
trump got eight percent of blackfoot in
2016. you know what percentage what do
you get this time
12 of the black vote he got more the
black vote than romney and mccain
combined so the conversation about
racism
is gone america doesn't believe that
latino votes i don't know about all that
but
no no no that that's out i mean the
people that want to propaganda that part
they can say that but that that
conversation is out okay
which conversation he's a racist he's
this he's that
that's out because that's increasing and
it's
becoming more out i think there's still
a lot of goals i think he's everybody
for making is mccain racist i don't
think any of them are quarters
mccain is racist i would not say that
okay he got three times more black voice
than mccain did think about that
this is the whole blexit yeah but he got
three
times more black vote than mccain got
twice as much as romney even
even as india's and they're both
like him they're both part of the
lincoln project mccain and romney
cindy mccain yes well i mean you just
got to put him i can't count then you
look at the latino and
mccain in in in when he ran he got 31
percent so he had the latino award
because it's arizona
then he had romney got 27 percent of
latino vote then trump got 28 in 2016.
then trump got 32 percent this time
around
32 that's not good for long-term
democrats because if it's at 32 in
climbing that means latinos are starting
to say listen man
and by the way it's what she said
earlier venezuela cuba a lot of these
folks are look we are not dealing with
socialism so the more socialism occurs
creates momentum you know we got a call
in from my buddy in miami who called in
and he was like my
my uncle died on a raft nelson oh my god
he's like oh adam i know you've found
the character
yeah yeah oh what's up nelson shout out
to them they've got their six degrees of
separation
and you lived in uh i lived in caracas
so that's right i like how you
that's venezuela i mean that's like
legit so she said so
so you're saying what happened look i
tell you i respect the opponent
that out strategizes you in life i
believe in four things
outwork out improve out strategize out
less trump outworked
okay let's just face it trump out work
there's no question he outworked
there's no question he outlasted he
lasted a longer time
okay where he's going the last day five
rallies all the stuff that he's doing
they did not out strategize they did not
out strategize
the democrats out strategized it's that
simple they united
by the way you know what's crazy so
think about it this way in sales
you know how you're selling something
and you
make the offer of what you're going to
ask later on in the presentation but you
ask it early and you it's simple it's
something like
look john is it fair to look i get paid
based on commission
and i get paid based on taking care of
you if i show you
you know if i if i'm able to take care
is it fair to say you're gonna you know
help me out with referrals you say what
yes yeah if i say that in step two of my
presentation
i'm preparing myself on step number nine
i've already prepped you right you know
why i'm here
i'm asking i'm gonna give you some
evidence and then i'll go for the closed
deal can you tell me when the democrats
started saying
vote they've been saying it for six plus
months when have the republicans
how long have republicans been seeing it
not as long as the democrats exactly so
now watch this what organization did the
democrats win over
to keep saying vote vote vote tell me
what the organizations that the
democrats went over well the first thing
that comes to mind is the nba
yeah so so you got the nba what else do
you have
i'm taking the lincoln project what else
do you have um
i mean the entire democratic uh
hollywood well hollywood obviously put
it on this side because it doesn't get
quite
hollywood whatever social media what
else do you have i mean the list goes on
and on and on what do you got so you got
sports
you got hollywood yep you got a social
you got the right you got
you got the rock you got all these guys
so they came together and
quite frankly um they they started
selling this six months ago and
republicans started two months ago
in 2018 when that when the house flipped
we have to vote we have to vote strategy
wise
man you just got to give it up to your
strategy you have to say that
there was there was a concerted effort
on the port on the part of the
republican party that was
that was organized in texas that was
organized in florida
that was organized in latin strongholds
that did have a successful get out the
vote campaign
can you tell me a big democrat that
didn't support the democrats
a big democrat that no no okay can you
hear a couple
give me a big name uh he's not a big
name but there was a
there was a state legislator in atlanta
i'm sorry in
georgia they came out and spoke about
the primary you don't even know the name
can you tell me the republican that
didn't support the republican a lot of
them yes
mccain john kasich colin powell
romney said i didn't vote for trump
right so the governor of the state of
new hampshire who's a republican came
out and said i have just voted
the entire
here's the difference between
republicans and democrats repub who has
a bigger ego republicans are democrats
republicans who has bigger egos i think
republicans who has
more of the mindset of arania i can do
this on my own republican republicans
so the problem is like dude i don't need
you you know i got you i can you know
you
whatever yeah they're so competitive
with each other because their spirit is
competition right like how much time did
how many times did
uh trump call out fellow loser
republican
loser mitt romney doesn't happen in the
democratic party far more
competitive which hurts them sometimes
democrats are very united their enemy is
one enemy
right so look at look at what was going
on behind the scenes
so trump after john mccain died
trump continued to criticize him knowing
that it was hurting him
knowing that it was hurting him his
advisors are saying rest in peace
be quiet and on top of that he refused
to travel
to arizona he didn't want to be in an
overnight situation where i did sleep
overnight somewhere else
so his campaign advisors are saying you
are blazing a trail across this country
you
we've never seen such energy you gotta
physically go to arizona
no i don't want i don't i don't like it
you never went to arizona's what you're
saying and on top of that you see his
rally in arizona though
the 96 mile long uh trump oh my god
i got it i got it but he didn't
physically come to arizona and arizona
earlier in arizona was one of the
hardest hit states
when it came to coronavirus fatalities
because of the
demographics because it's an older state
so
he had three things going against him in
the state that he didn't correct for
by going there when's the last time a
democrat won
arizona do we know that oh gosh you can
pull it up kai because it's based on
that list when you look at
states you know that whole thing we look
at and what also kai also when's the
last time a democrat won
georgia jimmy carter
gosh that's probably 76 that's probably
true
i mean just think about these states
that
biden is potentially going to win and if
he doesn't win for whatever reason
razor thin margins he has flipped states
that have traditionally voted republican
arizona 96 was arizona clinton and
that's because of
well that was ross pro wasn't in that
one and what about georgia kai
kai on the ones and two shout out to our
norwegian nightmare over there kai doing
our research nightmare about norway
norwegian
the the good kind of nightmare you don't
want them on you don't want them in your
dreams
92 georgia so yeah it's the raspberries
yeah
yeah got it plus he was a boy from the
south
so 160 million votes but there is a
there is a movement that has occurred
in fulton county i mean you have to
atlanta
atlanta yeah and you keep saying
maricopa county what what city is that
tucson is that phoenix
interesting and he won trump won phoenix
handily
handily in 2016. right here here's a
very interesting
here's the point i would love to get
your guys perspective on this um
pick a pick any major city in america
any major city in america
they voted blue you go to the
red estate in america go to oklahoma
yeah go to west virginia
go to kansas go to nebraska pick
any major city in those states they
voted democrat
and then so you look at any state pick a
state go on a map
louisiana they vote red alabama they
vote red mississippi they vote red
oklahoma they vote red the list goes
alaska they've yeah they've all read
look at any major city in any state in
america
they voted democrat and then so you have
these wide swaths of red
red red red and then boom targeted major
cities
boom in major cities what's the story
there obviously there's no secret rule
america
goes trump goes republican every single
major city
goes blue and i know there's someone out
there they're going to be like well
there's one city in
west virginia i get it okay let's i
won't say 100 let's say 99.9
yep it's it's not so much left first
right no
it's it's conservative versus liberals
cities versus liberal i mean
when you're talking about cities you're
talking about city
funding city budgets public pensions
you're talking about the need for fiscal
federal aid in many cases i mean your
biggest example is the city of chicago
but that's you know that is your extreme
example but whittle that down to every
big city in most states in the united
states and you're going to have
similar big city type of issues and that
is that
you are you you tend to have
uh bigger fire departments you tend to
have you know the teachers
union think about texas and austin and
where is all of texas
pension money run in austin taxes that's
that's the democratic stronghold
of our state here where we are so any
city that has
massive public financing issues tends to
need more federal assistance well let me
ask you this danielle because that's the
the the socio-economic component for the
most part right there
what about just the social component
what's this this is more of a question
than an answer i'd love to get your
perspective
what's the reason that's part of it
clearly is
is there something to be said for in
cities
you're surrounded by all sorts of people
if you're in chicago if you're in new
york city if you're in l.a if you're in
miami if you're in dallas
you're meeting white people latinos
asians gays straights this that
everything fat skinny whereas if you're
in rural you're like man get
the hell off my property i'm over here i
got my let me be
just i'm not surrounded by all these
different type of people i don't got
these latinos over here i don't have you
know
blacks coming here like rural america is
white so that's why i'm giving that
example
what about the social component where
are your thoughts on that
i'm gonna i'm gonna let patrick jump in
here yeah
so so i mean the way i would look at it
is a different way here's how i would
say to you
what's what's easier to sell being a
republican or being a democrat
being a democrat which principles is
easier to sell
to sell so say i'm i'm somebody that's
clueless about politics
and i'm sitting here and i say honestly
i have no clue what to vote for you i
don't know and i'm just a regular person
making 50 60 70 grand a year
what's an easier thing to sell what
concept
depends what your pitch is the pr okay
so what how do you how do democrats push
themselves
as givers as givers okay we're there for
the people
we support you we want we want to
increase your minimum wage
affairs day's work yeah well i mean if
the republican party said you want to be
left alone
just a simple quote what's easier to
sell excuse me just like someone's
giving you free stuff that's probably
easier
easier to sell do you want an easier
life or do you want a harder life now
watch the republicans you know the
father that
kids grow up not liking what does a
father say make you stop crying get your
act together make your bed
get out to save your money get to work
you need a job get off the couch right
i mean shake it off that father who the
hell likes that he just fell down a
flight of steps get up shake it off yeah
exactly
yeah and you know that damn you see them
on football games basketballs don't go
i mean i was a kid i'm going around the
track uh a bike every kid is
on this bike track and my dad were in
iran and i parked shanghai and shaheed
and i said that i want to go the other
way he says they're going to hit you
i said i'm going the other way he says
okay do what you want to do but you're
going to get hit
so all the kids are going this way i
start going to just the famous story the
david family they keep telling each
other so everyone's going like this 60
70 kids
i'm going this way and i'm like oh my
gosh it feels like i'm going faster
then i'm looking at my dad boom i hit a
kid i fly off the bike i fall on the
ground
i'm bleeding everywhere the kid is
bleeding everywhere
kids parents run up what is the matter
with you
they say who's your parents a point of
my dad i point on my dead might that's
pointing out
david shout out my my dad's pointing at
the water faucet he says go wash
yourself
he didn't come to me so i went and
washed myself but i'm not crying the
other kid is crying
he says okay so what are you going to do
which way you want to i think i'm going
to go the other way
okay go the other way right what's the
moral of the story that's an annoying
uh quality you know you want your dad to
run up to you oh my gosh baby are you
good
that's the difference so but what's good
for you so when you say that i don't
know what's your point because to me
it's like
whose message is easier to buy into when
i'm naive
that message is a lot easier message
you're assuming that there's people who
are just completely clueless
and that's why they're voting democrat
do you remember the video i showed on
the on the marathon where i showed uh
rfk when mlk died and he got up and he
gave the speech powerful speech and he
said
you know i i have some bad news for you
martin luther king was just shot and
killed and then you hear this in the
crowd
gasped crowd gasps right and then he
says there's two ways we can handle this
situation one is what
one is to go out there revenge angry and
the other one the other or we can come
together like martin luther king
he says the bad news is the man that
killed your
martin luther king was a white man he
says the interesting stories i relate to
because i just had a loved one as well
recently
died and he was also killed by a white
man which is john f kennedy
so but that happens today
if today and modern day mlk gets shot
and the modern day rfk gets up and gives
a speech is that what he's going to say
i don't know if that's what they're
going to say today i think the messaging
today is very divisive today
i think the way the democrats are
selling today they're selling trump's
racist
they're selling republicans or races
they're selling and
quite honestly it's easier to sell
people on emotions rather than logic
emotions it's easier said than logically
maybe this is a good time saying
speaking of is there someone that can
come out and speak
at some point during the show today we
should show what biden had to say
because what he had to say is actually
very powerful and it's something that i
wish
i campaigned as a democrat but i'll go
back
for everyone there's like an american it
was actually a very powerful statement
that he came out with
and it it's um and it is something that
is definitely
getting under the skin of the
progressives and the far left
in the party because as much as he is
delivering
a message to all of the united states
and everybody in it and saying
you will all be my constituents he's
also implicitly
saying i'm not going to necessarily be
pliable and i'm not necessarily going to
be drawn
into your narrative and what you want to
do
so i'm going to govern for everybody and
i mean the undertone of his statement is
to me
very reassuring i love it yeah i i'm
very is reaching out more to the right
than the progressive
left i think that's what he needs to do
i mean and and look
it and there are a lot of people who are
going to be conservative
in their bones and that this will appeal
to if he wants
if he gets this next six electoral votes
and he crosses the 270 line
theoretically you know how are you going
to work with
a a gop led senate how are you going to
work with mitch mcconnell
and that's what you have to be i mean
either you're going to get legislation
done or you're not
he was witness to obama not getting a
lot of legislation done over an
eight-year period
maybe he was doing a lot of
ribbon-cutting ceremonies at the time in
his position as vice president
but he witnessed what it looks like to
have a mostly lame duck
presidency so maybe he can appreciate
the
importance of crossing the aisle because
he's going to have to figure it out
he's going to have to put centrists and
conservatives in that cabinet
or he's going to end up alienating the
senate you might as well be in gridlock
for the next four years and accomplish
exactly nothing if biden goes too far
left
just get ready for more and more and
more partisanship that we've seen of
course
since really george w bush left office
or even clinton
but if he actually goes right he has a
very elegant way to resolve this issue
um i don't know if we can play the uh
kai i don't know if we've got this
queued up but
bernie sanders a few days ago the day
the day before the election bernie
sanders is
he's he's doing a zoom call with the
quad with the squad
squad the four ladies yeah yeah there he
is
yeah and you know they look at him like
a god by the way
all of us are working very hard to make
that happen but we understand
that electing biden is not the end all
it is the beginning
okay and i think as the result of the
work
that all of you have done biden's
proposals
in this campaign are a lot stronger than
they were in the primary alexandria
i was on the climate change task force
did a great job
uh and his proposals are stronger do
they go as far as
we would want no they don't okay
biden unlike trump does not conceive of
himself as a dictator that means
you have your job in the house i've got
my job with others in the senate
and we're not giving up on our agenda
for example one area
you know biden wants to expand health
care that's good what's the lower
prescription drug cost
that's great wants the double funding
for community health centers
very important but you know when i know
that at the end of the day
the only way that we're going to provide
quality care to every man woman and
child
in an affordable way is through medicare
for all
and we ain't giving up on that struggle
well all right we're going to introduce
medicare for all believe me we are and
we have because of
all of your efforts and the efforts of
great doctors
nurses and others throughout the country
we've got a majority of the people who
support us
so thank you for that green new deal we
ain't giving up on that we know
my god i mean every day positive the
horrors are going on
yeah because he can go on and on and on
but you notice that that's a screen full
of
people in congress house of
representatives senators
i mean look biden can come in on day one
and say
i am my own man i'm going to be choosing
my own
cabinet and there will be no members of
the u.s house of congress
uh who are going to be members of my
cabinet moving on to the next thing
and you think he's going to do that i
think it's
you know jamie dimon wrote some very uh
jamie diamond alluded to that in some
public comments that he made recently
i bring up jamie dimon because he runs
the largest bank in the country and
if you're going to have a successful
administration
you might want to have the biggest banks
on board with you they might be more
important
so again if he crafts a cabinet
that is more reaganesque and less
left then i i think he will have a much
easier
task on his hands plus the fact that
nancy pelosi has lost seats
six of them so the the the democratic
stronghold in the house is not as strong
as it was so uh you know there are three
seats left one seat went
um to the democrats last night in in the
senate
so uh that was a bit of a surprise so
now you're down to three seats it still
looks like republicans are going to
retain control of the senate and that is
a harder grasp
than when you've got a house that can
float either way because there's so many
more moving
people moving parts but she has lost
some control
of that house it's it's up to joe biden
to
choose a cabinet that can work with all
of them
will she stay the speaker pelosi yes
she's that's not changing and mcconnell
and her are going to go at it
well they have been but but the elements
basically nothing's changing the element
that that has brought them together
traditionally has been steven mnuchin
and that so let me let me ask you guys
another question let me ask you another
question
by the way just so no all the
valuetainers i see your commentary and
i'm going to ask them right now to just
kind of see what
what they think how much of fraud do you
think went into this election
how much fraud you know i i think that
there are there is a
chance that there is some fraud that's
gone on was it the fraud that got j.f
kennedy
john f kennedy into office no i mean you
didn't have
two entire states uh where there were
numerous hundreds of thousands of dead
people voting
so um yes there might have been a tiny
bit of fraud i think uh
and there's likely fraud in every single
election and they'll be fraud in the
2022 midterms
and that's just a part of life but again
it was great weather
nationwide you had the highest turnout
you had 66.9
turnout in this election you have to go
back to the year 1900
that's the last time we have this high
voter 20 years
1900 the presidential election
so again percentage-wise
percentage-wise yes what was the
percentage 73.2
turnout in 1966.9 turnout in 2020
and because again i mean weather is a
you know if you've got a foot of snow on
the ground in the midwest
you're not going to have that many
people voting it was unusual
you brought up there was a nice weather
day it was it was a nice weather day
nationwide and you had lots of people
voting
on election day as well and when you
listen to the states
whether it's the attorney general of
michigan or wisconsin they're like it
was just a normal day we had just a few
snafu's here and there
you had polls open late in atlanta they
compensated by that for staying open an
hour late
so uh it was a very smooth smoothly run
election day by the way if you're
watching this and if you think there was
voter fraud
press thumbs up push thumbs up if you
think there wasn't
any voter fraud to the point where it
could influence the entire election put
thumbs down so either thumbs up for yes
there was voter fraud thumbs down
there wasn't did you see the project
veritas video yesterday with michigan
i did not okay so do you know it came
out very late it came out like
i don't know what time but we came out
late do you know how many views it got
in the first seven hours on twitter
have you seen it million views how many
views you think got on twitter
on twitter twitter i don't know a couple
hundred thousand seven million i was
gonna say
seven hours can you pull up the video i
just want you to see what happens here
and you know for me i can tell the
difference between an act and when you
listen to the voice you don't hear
somebody that's acting
listen to this guy on how he speaks and
who he is that's two minutes
go ahead i work in the traverse city
post office more specifically the
barlow bridge your boss told you and
your colleagues something that shocked
you this morning what was it
we were issued a directive this morning
to
collect any ballots we find in mailboxes
collection boxes just outgoing mail in
general
separate them at the end of the day so
that they could uh hand stamp them with
the
previous day's date today is november
4th
for clarification who is your boss i
don't what is his title jonathan would
be a direct supervisor
so you know what they're saying they
were just a typical day it would be
clerks
doing it up at the distribution center
so 8 pm election day november 3rd
uh the court of appeals uh ruled ballots
have to be received by that time
and and what were you told they're
separating today so they could mark them
on yesterday's date
and send them through the express system
this appears to be an attempt to
circumvent michigan law and allow late
votes
and uh you said there was a hamper where
letter carriers were supposed to leave
their ballots
where are the ballots now they were
putting them into express bags
to go to the distribution center in
regards to a
hamper there's a standard hamper that
all letter mail's supposed to go to and
they have a top next to it that we were
supposed to
put in the balance collected
to other postal workers who see things
like this
how are we supposed to have any
integrity in this country
are you afraid of retaliation against
you uh i've had whistleblower
policies backfire on me in the past so
yes we'll have to reach out to jonathan
clark for comment
is this jonathan yes hey i'm a reporter
with project veritas and james o'keefe
here
and i have a i have information that you
guys have been stamping
ballots with the previous date november
3rd
you just have to call me you just take
up the phone on me
what's your reaction to that danielle um
i this type of
un unsubstantiated the sources unknown
could have come from anybody yeah but
why did a guy hang up
who's saying on the phone for that no i
don't know you but i'm about to call you
right away and basically accuse you how
many crazies do you think have called
that person all day long
but here's a question for you so both of
you are saying this is nothing
that's not what i said is that what
you're saying i don't know no no i'm not
saying it's nothing
i'm saying it is potentially something
that could be
investigated yeah but and should be
investigated
it should be investigated fair so
investigated so we put the election on
hold
and we investigate this to see if
there's anything to it before we
announce the president
i don't think the entire item is going
on hold because that's
mission 120 000 ballots
in michigan were dropped and in
wisconsin there were trump votes
played the other thing on what happened
in california here watch this one in
california
i mean you're seeing this stuff all over
the place and to me make the video in a
way
is there anything you can do to the
video kai or no
uh i wanna i wanna show this video see
if you can change the video in a format
um man you gotta find a video and maybe
copy paste it but go ahead you were
gonna say something
a couple different things obviously
there's people out there who are just
fraudulent fraudulent fraudulent
fraudulent fraudulent i'm not there
and i'm not in the fraudulent fraudulent
campaign you know what camp i'm
in what's that i'm in the count it once
count it twice count it three times
bring it to the
supreme court there's no chance i want
biden winning this election and having
four years of
he stole it it's it's all illegal i want
it to be
triple checked i'm on the same page
triple checked and if it comes out that
the
the vote calculations are totally off
and totally you lost you lost just man
up you lost there's no chance that i
want
four years of of more chaos in this
country so watch this i wanted to be
triple charlie called the state
because these are male 1 ballots
are there a ton in there yeah
all right are you collecting from a lot
of places by the way this is in
california yeah this country
but they called in very early california
you think california is flipping
but
all right and let me just ask you one
thing where do you guys take them
election stuff that's it watch what
happens when she gets close in the
government building
okay thank you
thank you are there a lot more in there
watch what he says get back it's six
feet
thank you guys i just want to see
because they called our state so quickly
i know i am
you don't have a you don't have a mask
either oh yeah sorry
are they allowed to do that are they
allowed to do that so so look
the the people the folks who are upset
saying there's voter fraud
i want to look at history of voter fraud
just to kind of see what
voter fraud happened last night and this
morning because i'm actually curious now
for voter fraud right
so do you know how elections were up
until 1804 do you know how we chose
presidents and vice presidents up until
you had duels and you would shoot your
opponent yeah well that was that was
actually not a bad setup right but
do you actually know how they did it
like i didn't know i didn't know this
danielle did you know how they did it up
until 1804
no i wasn't around then so so when you
and i ran if you got 2 million i got 1
million 9
you become the president i become the
vice president awesome oh yes
yes yes pretty intense i mean you heard
about news you're number two you lose
your number two
first or less bite would become
president unless you're saying trump
will because
so biden would have four more years of
ribbon cutting yeah so that's
but just think about it basically that's
how would you imagine the fact that i
my brain when my mind went there dude
thinking what if that actually was the
case i love it so that's up until 1804.
now in 1803 there was something called
cooping
are you familiar with cooping i know
about riding in a coupe you know when
you know what coupe you know what
cooping was called
here's what cooping was cooping back in
the days and this went until 1920 by the
way they stopped
it went up until al capone cooping was
they would find people in the streets
they would pull you off they would get
you drunk they would give you drugs they
would disguise you to go vote multiple
times for different people
and by the way craziest story edgar
allen poe
died outside of a voting poll on
election day
and they say he was one of the folks
that was
used for cooping so this is the famous
author so so now so then
so then you continue you continue up
until 1890 do you know up until 1890 how
they did election
you had to publicly say who you voted
for okay so you
exactly so you would you asked her a
question yesterday
would you be willing to tell us but up
until up until 1890
you would say i'm voting for trump i'm
voting for biden and
everybody would love no not up until
1890. that's true okay
so then they said listen this is a
little too out of control it's going to
piss people off nobody can keep it a
secret so some people actually didn't
want to come out and vote
because they said i'd rather not vote
than tell people
who i'm voting for they say we got to
change it
so then eventually around 1890 or so
they changed it to a secret ballot and
secret ballot was a system that they
took from australia it's how australia
did it for longest time
so this led to the largest change
because now you could go and it was
specific rules and guidelines they put
up it was in an indoor space in public
buildings run by government officials
there will be a single ballot to produce
by states the ballot would obtain
contain the names of the candidates with
an option to also write in
the ballot will be completed in total
privacy that's what happened there now
from that time even with secret ballots
fraudsters still showed up because of
impersonation at the polls
false registration duplicate voting
fraudulent absentee votes buying votes
illegal assistant at the post
ineligible voting altering vote count
ballot petition fraud
and since 1980 there's been a thousand
seventy one instances of voter fraud
even even in
1071 instances of voter fraud
since 1980 so in the last 40 years
which is a small number there's a very
small number 1071.
by the way the chances of there being a
voice i'll give you the percent i'm
actually going to give you guys some
some content here the chances of voter
fraud
is between point zero zero zero
four zeros four percent up to point
zero zero zero nine percent so point
zero zero
zero zero four two point zero zero zero
nine so essentially less than less than
less than less than one percent less
than less than less than one percent yes
but there's been a thousand seventy 71
cases
of voter fraud and i think the biggest
concern people have right now
do you know how many votes bush beat
gore buy
and in two do you know how many votes
there's like a couple thousand
votes in florida maybe even a couple
hundred something i don't think it was a
couple hundred thousand i think it was
no a couple hundred
yeah it was five thirty nine yeah
rejected in the state that
florida not 539 million voters 539
okay voters guys so right now
as as of 99
of votes having been counted to that
because god knows it's going to be
running around on my twitter feed later
on
right now biden has a 241 000 count
lead over trump in the state of michigan
yeah
a quarter million almost yeah so i'm
that's a massive lead but by the way
even if
that's a mess thank you for 120 000.
even if the whistleblower
is correct and there was an instance if
you will and he did his civic duty and
rightly so and and blew the whistle even
if that's the case
241 000 is a plenty big margin
right you you have to do a recount
automatically if your margin is in
between one percent
it's not you could drive a golf cart
through it so it's it's you're right
it's not wisconsin is but michigan is a
different story and danielle let me say
one thing thank you for bringing that up
because i actually found out how you
know the total
the guy was like armored the travel
surgery uh barlow branch
you know the total population of
traverse city 15 000.
total population in traverse city
michigan i've been there it's upstate
michigan
yeah but he's on the barlow branch so
meaning he's in one post office
in a 15 000 person city so let's just
say that there was some shady stuff
let's say that guy was absolutely right
shady as hell maybe there's a couple
hundred votes
maybe a couple thousand maybe you just
said there's only been a thousand
instances of voter fraud in 40 freaking
years so let's say that guy was sure to
throw what are we talking about a couple
hundred votes but
you have to know that i mean for you
have to know there is
a much bigger chance to do voter fraud
with mail-in ballots
much bigger chance to the voter fraud
with mailing ballots of course if you
don't agree with that you're naive
yourself
there's a much to say a hundred and
sixty million
people voted biden got more votes than
by
than uh obama are you saying he's a
better candidate than obama i mean it's
not even
it's you by the name of a campaign and
he got more than more than uh uh uh or
obama did so the the mainland ballots
change the game
so if you really go through the game if
you really go through the game
and if you if you go to a complete dark
side okay
go complete dark for a quick second here
uh uh coronavirus hits you shut down
what a brilliant strategy to shut down
and say we have to do mail-in balance
we have to do mailing ballots we have to
do mailing balances we're going really
dark here
if we do if we do i mean if you if they
can i get a ray of sunshine sometimes
strategically if you do great strategies
guys i have a great
favorite let's go let's go to china
let's eat some bats
develop a pandemic we'll get the mail-in
ballots we'll get the voter fraud we'll
get the dude in michigan
we got this thing and we're going to win
by like one percent you know what
i had somebody on my twitter feed still
on on monday saying this is going away
this is going away on wednesday the
coronavirus disappears
oh nice vanishes and there are a lot of
them out there a lot of them out there
and so to that person whoever you are
because you're you hide behind an avatar
because
it's such a sign of strength picture
didn't he didn't have a picture
character no no no hiding behind
something anonymous
you don't give this as drake likes to
say but yeah trigger fingers turn to
twitter fingers
like everyone's tough on twitter the
toughest people i know you know my reply
to him
you know in italy too like everywhere
yesterday
johns hopkins reported that there were
there were more than 10
000 deaths worldwide from the
coronavirus we've never crossed that
line ever
worldwide you know what daniel stop it
yesterday stop it daniel we are rounding
the turn i'm just saying there's
we've already rounded it if if you if
you want to talk about what alienated a
lot of people
in this country and where he may have
lost
senior voters senior voters
um it was because he called the
coronavirus a blessing
and trump trump calling it a blessing
to his evangelical religious base
many of whom are older and have lost
friends to the coronavirus
might have been a step too far yeah by
the way the u.s just set a record for um
86 000 a day average corona cases yes
according to wall street journal i don't
know if they're fake news or not but
coordinators we have more than 100
000 cases here we're up to 53 000
hospitalizations we're 11 percentage
points off of
peak hospitalizations and we've had
fatalities in the united states
north of eleven hundred for two days
running this does not affect
the garden is gonna fix that to be going
around um it was interesting because
uh because biden can't fix it
biden cannot fix it it's not the way our
government
was designed originally biden can come
out and say
there is a national mass mandate in
theory
he cannot enforce it what the states
have to enforce that to the states
yeah that is in the hands of the states
so
as strong as he could theoretically be
and as unifying as he could
theoretically be
to say hey this is not this is not
metaphor kids
winter cometh and you know be a little
be a little safer be a little more
distance
you you know think wiser act wiser
he can say all he wants it will still
come down
to the states and unlike europe i doubt
that we're going to have
so then how does that game of covert be
on trump though if you're saying if
you're saying biden can't fix it
there's a big uh uh uh you know
in media everybody's saying well if i
was this i would have handled different
ways to you know
this person was he would handle
different way and i'm asking now would
buy
biden make it go away or sim biden can't
do anything about it but you're saying
it's trump's fault so
talk to hospital administrators and
hospital administrators i'm talking
about in timbuktu and
right now rural areas are getting hurt
by the coronavir is much worse than the
big cities
but talk to hospital administrators and
they're like all of this funding from
the cares act
which was out months ago all of the
funding through the cdc to release this
equipment was months and months ago
we're still waiting
send us the damn equipment so there have
been holdups there have been
and you don't normally associate trump
with red tape he's the actual
opposite he's the aunt of antithesis
he's the red tape cutter
gets through regulations all the bs gets
the
but there are things that he can do very
quickly
in terms of bolstering up hospitals that
need equipment
just like that and that would be a
big relief so then so then how could
biden
help like do you think biden's going to
be better with coronavirus
that i'm talking about what biden could
do he could actually
listen to the medical community
throughout the country saying
we need this we need that and actually
deliver on it
as opposed to not deliver on it yeah
because they're still waiting i will
tell you if california
all of a sudden opens up in the next
four to six weeks
after biden wins and disneyland opens up
very very you know political type of a
move right there
all of a sudden they open up oh my gosh
biden solved the problems the moment he
came in everybody
opened up so now watch what's going to
happen you know what's going to be funny
if it flips and all fox now talks about
is covet cases
can you imagine if it flips that's where
it's going to be really funny if that
really takes place
but if all of a sudden wait wait wait
wait wait a minute if they all of a
sudden say
if they all of a sudden say look how
amazing he is biden came
economy opened up people are back
working and they make him look at heroes
the reality is the most regulators on
these governors that
shut down they're liberals so if they
open it up they're going to make biden
look good they're going to make them
look real good let me let me add some of
that by the way you were looking for a
little race
sunshine wall street journal reports
astrazeneca we've heard their name
a bunch expects a vaccine this year by
the end of the year this year i think
you know whether you're left or right or
you know martian for that matter
uh i think we would all it is good for
the market so that happened under
trump's administration that's never
happened under 18 months so you got to
give that man a lot of credit you like
playing games
right let's play a game let's play a
game
i'd like to know i mean trump is 74
years old
okay um let's play a game
let's say he wins this election somehow
there's a you know less than 20 15
chance yeah let's say he loses yeah
you know what what's the famous line um
uh losers don't get to write the history
quote
help me out here with quote winners
write history there's going to be a
different narrative if trump wins
re-election wins eight years there's a
story behind it
you know comes in and shakes the system
up
and rocks things he's there for eight
years gets reelected i mean he can write
that story
he does not get reelected what do what
does his
tombstone his obituary sound like if he
only wins four years
versus eight years what does that sound
like to you
i think i think his uh
and this is a shame because of what he
did
uh in the beginning of his term because
of some of the funding
that went into african-american colleges
because of opportunity zones and other
efforts that were made because
of him tearing back regulations because
he made it
easier to do business in america
uh and was kind of
the architect of bringing the
unemployment rate down to a 50-year low
a lot of that was federal reserve policy
a lot of it was but it was also making
it easier to do business in america
which at last
check it should be easy it's america
there should have never been all that
red tape in the in the obama years
period end
but i'm not so sure that history is
going to give him that credit
because of where the economy is headed
now
and because the coronavirus has hit uh
the minority working population so
so hard so it's going to remain to be
seen if if we're entering a dark
chapter in us history then
you could look to spiteful historians
especially
spiteful historians who feel like
they've been marginalized
in a trump world think about your
typical political pundit
who's basically been you know in
hibernation for the last four years
inside the beltway
he hasn't he hasn't needed people to
tell him
what to think nor has he needed advisers
to tell him what to say
he thinks it he tweets it i mean there's
really no
there's no stopping him in between um
but it it it is possible that he not
gets the credit that he deserves
for some of the things that he did
accomplish for the u.s economy
what do you think it sounds like if he
only wins four years versus eight years
listen
let's just face it this is one of the
most competitive if not the most
competitive person we've had as a
president in the history of america yeah
it's extremely competitive at least the
last 50 years that we know of
all the other stuff i don't disagree
okay he's extremely competitive but
i don't mind having a guy like that on
my side i just don't i don't mind having
a guy like that on my side
he's going to hate it he will be
miserable he will hate life
too personal like that it'll be very
very hard for him publicly he'll
act fine deep down inside the guy cannot
stand
losing he hates losing when michael lost
you felt the pain you
know he hated it and you loved him for
it because you loved
how much it mattered to him that he lost
that's where he's at
he's going to hate losing and i love
that i love the fact that it matters so
much to a guy who is going to hate
losing
is he going to be the kind of a guy
that's going to come out and say well
you know we've
lost you know we lost and they want fair
and square i
i'm gonna say no he's not gonna do that
he's gonna come out he's gonna put a
comment and say well you know
it is what it is now what are they gonna
write about him meaning like that's what
i'm gonna i'm gonna say this to you if
you give me a second so we've had
we've had uh uh three uh one-term
presidents in the last
50 years 40 years you had what ford
carter
senior practice hoover yeah senior of
course went against but
you know first of all ford anomaly
you know put him on a completely
different side because of what hap how
he became a president he didn't even win
reelection for whatever you know ford is
ford
so then you have a uh carter who won the
worst presidents we've had nicest guy
nice guys a horrible president
uh we had just i'm in america because of
carter just so you know that there's no
carter i'm still in iran i'm here in
america because of carter
i was about to say that so so bring
carter back in the discussion continue
and then you have uh bush senior which
honestly
bush senior to me was more of a cool he
was never ceo there's a difference
between a ceo
and he's never number one no he's not a
number one he's a guy behind closed
doors that's a great project manager
give him a project he will lead it he'll
get it done that was him he was never
the guy that's going to come out and
inspire people it's just
you never saw him like that and ross
perot showed up from texas he will be
trump will be the uh will be loved
admired adored by a lot of people on his
side now
is he going away that's the question the
question isn't really
legacy because legacy's gonna have both
sides there's gonna be a size that's
gonna comedians are gonna
love trashing them well they're the next
no no no no no it's gonna go to hold you
i think it's gonna get even odd
it's gonna go to a whole different way i
can't wait for snl whose reaction what
they're going to
it's going to go to a whole different
level if he loses comedians are going to
rock the house saying i told you so
this guy they're going to crush the tv
the don lemons of the world the cuomo's
of the world the coopers they're going
to be
loving life the next four years however
he's 74. in four years he'll be biden's
age
if there is anybody that's the kind of
person that's going to prepare the next
four years to make a comeback and come
and ruin these guys lives if there's one
guy that would do something like that
it's trump can he run again in four
years yes he can
okay yes oh he will yeah he can't he'll
be running against him
it's happened before so you're answering
my question you're actually answering my
question
jimmy carter uh
rank rank presidents uh
living living presidents who have
brought
more to their country current living
presidents
that have brought meaning what like done
good done good for their country in
their lifetimes
living presidents clinton that have done
good meaning they did a good time when
there were four years they didn't get
for the economy after they left office
including their time after office oh
carter's uh carter's a
non-profit charity guy involved active
yeah he just wasn't a good president
foreign relations terrible president
continuing to to work
outside of america on america's best
betty ford is the same if you put the
ford family they did as well there's a
lot yes sure
but but carter's legacy is pretty
incredible
not as a president for for how bad his
presidency is as a human being
and okay uh w george w
he disappeared and has been what
gracious even though he was he never
undermined obama
obama has done his the message from
trauma now he never undermined obama
even the obama everyday
said i got a bad administration he
trashed bush but bush never trashed
obama
dignified big time big time dignified
yeah i mean i got his picture there in
my office because i like the way he
handled himself but what he did is he
disappeared he didn't want the limelight
he gave it to obama
right sure and and and obamacare and
his legacy now is there for christine
sure
so i wouldn't say pristine he went into
the iraq he caused it
he doesn't there were a lot of things
there were there's still people that
don't like personality is
is i understand well-regarded but some
of his policies
right but i'm not talking about what he
did as president i'm talking about
legacy
yeah four years from now let's say trump
does not run what does his legacy look
like
well that's essentially that's what i
was to who to the country
as a whole i don't see it that way i
think i think forever
there is a playbook for future trumps
forever
everybody who sees themselves as a trump
who's not a career politician who wants
to one day run for office
whether they're a democrat or republican
trump officially gamed the playbook
oprah
rock trump officially gave him the
playbook trump gave him the playbook to
say
trump secretly is many people's hero but
they cannot say
publicly listen many people voted for
trump you know how you ask people and
say who'd you vote for i'm not going to
say you voted for trump
who the hell would say i'm not going to
say if you voted for biden you you like
for example you know
remember wait a minute remember megyn
kelly remember megan kelly
megan kelly years ago she tried to play
the card because she wanted to be oprah
i don't know if you guys remember she
wanted to get like an oprah contract she
couldn't get that so megan kelly in 2016
she's got
she's passed up bill o'reilly people are
watching making kelly more than watching
bill o'reilly everybody's like dude i'm
tuning in to making kelly
and then all of a sudden megan kelly
started playing the card of
i'm not really this i'm not really that
and she she
got the contract and then she got the
contract and she trashed fox where's
megan kelly today
where's mick if megan kelly would have
stood ground
and said look i have problems with fox i
don't like this thing
but i'm going to do this and i'm going
to stay to my positions megyn kelly
would have ruled the world today i agree
but what happened
there is this community she went
hollywood there is this community that
is
afraid of uh where they're going to be
secretly
millions of people admire trump and a
lot of people are going to use this
guy's playbook
dude you got to realize i mean you know
how hard it is to
give not give credit to a guy that his
entire career
he played business he did everything he
ever wanted
and then at the end of the day he says
you know what i'm going to go freaking
run for office
out of 16 people the only person that
said this guy is going to win it all was
who
was the only crazy psycho you know woman
that said
oh this guy's going to win it and bill
barr says
if it ends today trump's when he's like
what are you out of your mind
obama made fun of him everybody robert
downey
i'm not robert downey jr george clooney
everybody
joked about this guy and he won
against hillary clinton who was supposed
to be madame secretary queen of
the world he beat hillary clinton so
there is a part that legacy wise this
guy changed the game
love him or hate him he changed the game
look i don't have to like lebron to know
he changed the game
i don't have to like somebody to see a
person change a game trump
absolutely changed the game win or lose
but i'm going to tell you
listen adam there are certain people
when they make millions they disappear
there are certain people in the game of
basketball they win one championship
they disappear
there are certain people they get a nice
corporate job they disappear there's
certain people that you used to lose to
they get this much of a victory they
disappear this is not that guy
no just so you know this this is not
that guy and not only
is he not going to disappear so people
say well he's going to disappear when he
dies
absolutely not even when he dies
whatever he dies
the trump spirit is gonna be in so many
younger def
if he loses i'm gonna tell you what's
gonna happen if he loses say he loses
say he loses brother
danielle if this guy loses
you officially have a group of
tens of thousands not millions because
it's not true believers
tens of thousands of true believers that
are not going to forget this
and we're going to see what they're
going to be doing the next 2 4 6 8 10
20 years so he parlays this into i mean
the the running theory the conventional
wisdom
is that he parlays this into his own
network
that he unseats fox fox news
he could easily do that he becomes the
next rupert murdoch he could easily do
that but i don't know i don't
i i don't know if he is going to be
satisfied with just that because
you know when you've reached a
mountaintop of a certain business you're
just kind of like annoyed by it
and you go and you start negotiating
with other dignitaries and presidents
and prime ministers
you really want to go back to
negotiating with other presidents of
ceos of companies you're bored you're
like dude i played this game already
who the hell wants to go win basketball
at ymca when you're playing at college
level when you're in the nba who wants
to go play against college love and
collar so where where can he go where
where where can he go to
to be bigger here's where he can go
phenomenal question here's where he can
go
where he can go is what republicans
haven't been doing
i'm in chicago at the ritz carlton a few
years ago five
before uh or before uh trump so put it
14 15. i'm at the ritz
and there's 2 000 african american men
and women in their 18 19 20 21.
sharp all look ridiculous
like i'm talking beautiful three-piece
suit the ladies wearing nice dresses
like the ones you put together
everybody's looking money right and i'm
like what are you guys doing here
with the future democratic lawyers
of the african-american community so
what's this all about he says well we're
a
private organization we come together
who's your hero barack obama
what do you guys want to be we're all a
running for one day maybe we'll be
president
and let me tell you it was so flipping
impressive
i'm like dang this is impressive so he's
breeding the next obama it's good for
you
if trump really loves america if he
really loves america
okay which but people who believe in him
believe that this guy really loves
america
and the foundation america was founded
on he wants to protect that if he does
the next thing he's got to do is figure
out more the university route the more
the education route the more the rally
and the next
troops rod duplicating himself right
it's not through corporation it's about
i'm gonna bring two three four thousand
young cats
and i'm gonna get this mindset in their
brain over and over and over and over
and over and over again
for this spirit to last for the next 50
600 years you're saying that's the
direction that he should go i don't
think the media is go i think the media
is going to be a small play for him
listen i'm not saying he can't do it i
think he could do it
but i think he's got you know two kids
that could one day run for office
he's got a son-in-law that could run for
office he's got
a son that's 14 years old that's one
they're going to be the center of
whatever but
he can run for office he could run for
office after he plays his professional
kids listen what happened to kenneth
legacy beyond you're saying now these
guys are not going to go away
they're not going to go away well you
know i mean the hoover institute it's
it's stanford very conservative
uh organization has been speaking
out vociferously saying that the
liberal university system in america is
killing uh free speech and the first
amendment and
you know what patrick i think that there
is an appetite to
bring balance back into higher education
in america such that it's not
such a one leaning way of thinking and
parents you know i've got kids who who
will be going to university in a few
years
i i completely applaud that i have why
pay
all this money intuition to send your
child off to be brainwashed in one way
i mean theoretically higher learning
should teach them how to think for
themselves
and not be brainwashed so if something
like that i think has
tremendous appetite in the united states
i agree so i'm
is a little bit more dignified than what
i would expect from trump so
good for him if he's going to raise the
bar for himself
to start influencing the next generation
of conservative thinkers in america
we need that no i i you you won't give
me your give me he's not a conservative
thinker that's not his
brand he he will he will look
listen uh capitalism marxism right
marxism is behind whose name a person's
names karl marx marxism
trump is not about i'm a conservative
republican trump would much like
rather have a trump system yeah trumpism
he is
about that right so he's not it has to
be branded around
populism isn't it isn't it like bravado
telling you i don't understand this guy
who he is i understand who trump is i've
been in business with people like trump
and you don't mind having a guy like
that on your camp
you don't mind having a guy like that on
your camera oh if you're going doing
business yeah hell no you don't mind
having to sign me up not only business
you would have loved a
democratic trump let me tell you
democrats would have loved a trump
that's a democrat
give me a give me a democrat who that's
true who would be
you guys are very quick to jump to
conclusion if that guy was wearing your
color jersey you
love him he's your guy give me wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait
i gotta i gotta do the big time out
right here because i i support the
person
so what did i get for supporting the
person when i was
when i when i lived in new york city
what did i get for supporting the person
because here comes hillary clinton
running for the senate in the state of
new york and i'm like
i don't get that not her state i don't
understand i i don't understand
i was raised so there i go i go register
i go register to vote change my driver's
license in the city of new york
i vote i go completely knowing
completely i'm wasting my vote
voting for this guy rick lazio who
nobody's heard of anymore
in new york or in new york so you know
i'd been living in new york for seven
years
the one thing new yorkers kept saying is
danielle don't get rid of your texas
driver's license don't ever
ever get a new york driver's license
don't ever vote
in the state of new york you will get
jury duty so fast your head spins within
two weeks
what do i get jury duty but i didn't
know who rick lazio was but i did know
that hillary clinton had no business
being in the state of new york
it wasn't her state so in order to vote
against her i went out and did my civic
duty and
registered as a republican in the state
of new york and went and voted for this
rick
person just to make my statement to
hillary
so don't don't ever pigeonhole me you
never know pigeonhole you with what
with which part if you just said if
trump said to him
no i i don't put you as a no i don't
think he was going to know where you are
i'm not going at you at all no i know
you were
he wasn't going to take out him i'm not
going at you what i'm saying is
i think trump would have been coming
back much better democrat
i i what i'm saying is it's not about
whether he would have made a better
democrat or republican
all i'm saying is if democrats had a
trump
they would adore him who's the
democratic trump let's say let's say
biden wins cool
he doesn't want to run for re-election
but democrats say you know what
cuomo who are you thinking as a democrat
i'm asking you
are you asking yeah i'm asking you who's
the democratic trump well you're not
you're not going to have many democratic
trumps
bloomberg is not a democratic trump
cuomo is not a democratic trump because
he hasn't
the only person that could be a
democratic trump the only person
and he's not as much of a true believer
as trump is the only person that could
is a cuban
the only person mark cuban he could
cuban could be a democratic trump
what about like how diplomatic is the
rock
hey brother let me tell you no no no
he's very diplomatic when it comes to
politics diplomatic how diplomatic is
cuban
now he's pretty brash he's not exactly
what i'm trying to say and he's a
billionaire and he's a spoiler and he's
a tv guy and he's a shark tanker the
closest
personality yeah not just a big
personality a person that's willing to
go to war
and likes the heat okay but he likes the
heat but go back to your point
go back to your point because it's
really important that we shape
not that we shape the thinking but that
we teach
that we teach college age kids how to
think for themselves
so i don't care i don't care what trump
is is is if it's trumpism that he's
selling or conservatism
that doesn't matter what we need in our
university system is
to get to get away from and to escape
free of
unilateral thinking it can't just be
left left left liberal liberal liberal
in all of our universities and colleges
because it's just a gigantic waste of
money
let me tell you why i respect trump i
know this is the angle we were going
we go here we go here's our respect
trump we asked about the obituary and
legacy
what have you it's pretty clear that
that biden has a
very very very likely path to 270 right
um think about who biden was running
against biden was running against trump
periods full stop who was trump running
against three major things
while he was running against biden in
the dnc
there's one he's running against covid
a freaking pandemic and the third thing
is he's running against the media
so trump is going against three very
powerful entities
and the pollsters pollsters you might
say
um and almost pulled it off
and and according to him did pull it off
so
trump's a fighter he's brash no doubt uh
there's high likelihood he'll be back in
just because i can see him getting super
salty and just getting
pumped up and getting riled up and like
what he's saying
in in the last debate i ran because of
you
joe biden so he's gonna look at what joe
biden potentially does over the next
four years and
and regroup uh if not we'll see where
the republican party goes
let me tell you he's just going to have
to lay off the big mac he will not he
will let me tell you what's going to
happen
what obama did you know what obama did
tell me
the fact that obama didn't stop
trashing trump after trump got elected
and do what bush did to him
trump is going to do to obama a million
times
more trump to obama trump and biden both
of them
he's going to go at their throats
non-stop for four years
it's gonna be at levels you've never
seen before but obama can just say one
thing that trump will
obama be like i was here for eight buddy
you were here for four have a nice day
you don't think trump's gonna like get
so heated just hearing that
do
if you want to go down and dirty trump
if you want to go high and classy and
well-worded obama
okay okay what i'm saying what happens
when he's being offered a million
dollars every time he stands in front of
a podium
what about it he takes it but what's
your what's your point though you mean
you don't get it you you don't think
he'll you don't think there's
any way that he'll take the former
president dignified ralph
no hell no no
no because you're not paying them a
million bucks to give that talk
the key word there was dignified
danielle you understand what i'm saying
you're not you're not giving a million
dollars to give that speech
if you want that speech you give it to
somebody else not to him you're giving
them the million dollars to come up and
talk trash
you're basically bringing him to the wwe
you're giving him the money for that but
it's about to be gangbusters and
he loses brother there is certain people
shouldn't lose
there are certain opponents you don't
want them to lose publicly
you just don't who else there's some
people you
you do not want a a a tiger an
mj you don't want certain competitors to
lose what do you mean you don't want
them to lose what does that mean
if you're their opponent you don't want
to beat them and i'll tell you what
there's a lot of there's 70 plus million
people that would love to see him lose
no
not to deal with that not the voters not
the voters the opponents
the opponents not the voters i still
think that they want him to lose
i don't disagree with you but i don't
disagree here's what i don't think
biden's going to do
i don't think biden is going to go at
trump's throat
i don't think i don't think biden has it
in his dna
i think kamala will oh yeah i don't
think biden will i don't think biden
will i think come on
biden will have an opportunity to
potentially at some point
pardon trump pardon trump
uh i think that's a where are you going
with that danielle yeah exactly so well
there are hundreds of thousands of
dollars of debts that become due that
are
presumably in a holding pattern as long
as he's still president
i mean his taxes are still under audit
no no i'm not talking about his taxes
she's not talking taxes she's talking
about other things but listen
to to say pardon you have to have things
to pardon you know it's
that's a technical question you're
asking it's like
when you're gonna stop beating your wife
you know type of a thing that's
automatically putting the guy as beating
his wife so i get what you did right
there but
all i'm saying to you is this guy is not
a guy you want to lose
and we're all going to see how he's
going to lose if he is who i think he
really is
um shit's about to go down here's
another question games games for playing
games
2024 who is a more likely
to win the presidency more likely
or be the candidate like pence
don jr who do you got
but she's going to be pence well i i i
said
presidential i'm just saying who's more
likely to win would be i just
to win i mean there's so much that we
have to get through in the next few
years i think midterms are going to be
we're playing a game here
neither of them could be around at all
if you're saying
most likely to win a presidential
election
don jr or mike pence 2024. oh gosh
mike pence by a country mile you think
so
we got to to do what to win to win or to
win 2022
if one of those two people i will i tell
you i agree with daniel because
the next two years is going to say a lot
we're going to learn a lot about the
next two years lots of weird things are
going on with america and the world
right now you've got a lot of things
that
have been on the sidelines we haven't
dealt with say with uh
what's going to happen with china with
the sanctions on china sanctions on iran
venezuela's still on the table brexit is
still going on covet is still going on
russia's still going on armenia is going
on
iran iran's going on turkey's going on
do you know how many things are going on
so
i get it there's there's going to be
things going on non-stop
but i'm trying to say to you is the next
and then by the way on top of that
congress senate
tax raise two years if they lease lose
house now
both they don't have the house and the
senate it's it's gonna be not a moving
part
i think that i'm i mean i'm genuinely
focused on these midterms
midterms how are we talking about
midterms right now we're not even past
the election yet
well let me let me focus on 2022 let's
talk to the entrepreneurs daniel i think
this is this is somewhere where you can
you can help the entrepreneurs and and
and and the the folks that are making
over 400 000 and the people that are job
creators and the people that are running
businesses tax planning you are assuming
that he's going to get these
taxes passed that's exactly what i'm
asking you so what i'm asking you is to
the people that are listening saying 21
to 28 corporate
20 to 39 six capital gains the
additional 12.3 on social security
will that pass in 2021 no when will that
pass
when i mean look
it's going to depend on how bad the
economy gets
and what mitch mcconnell is about to
do could be a big mistake so he's going
he's going to insist on a really small
stimulus package
because he right now is running a
victory lap for schools
hospitals and small businesses
we held the line we were fiscally
conservative coming into this election
we held the senate we were rewarded for
being typical true conservative
republicans so but unfortunately the
economy
really could care less about that
because of the depth of
permanent joblessness that we're seeing
we've
i mean we've got this morning we had new
data out you know we've got 2.3 million
people who've lost their jobs
permanently
lost their jobs layoff announcements
continue to come
all of a sudden corporate america has
woken up nike corporations like you know
what
we got all these middle managers let's
cut them out there go 700 people in
beaverton oregon
yesterday in austin texas a big tech
company was like
you know what we've got too many middle
managers off go 650
so there are underlying economic
impediments to fiscally conservative
paths that mitch mcconnell
might try and hold the line on but i do
think when it comes to
taxes good luck
so meaning they're not changing the
compromise that you would potentially
contemplate
i think it will be very easy again if
if biden stays centrist i think you'll
maintain that low and
competitive thank you very much
corporate tax rate
and i just i i again nancy pelosi does
not have the same stronghold
on the house of representatives that she
did before this election
so i think something like a capital
gains tax is going to be really
really difficult again as you're seeing
white collar layoffs people
making 400 000 a year and losing their
jobs
stimulus will never touch them but they
can do damage to the economy
so what what what is and is not done in
in congress i
just wrote i just published 4 500 words
about infrastructure spending in america
if they're smart and they do something
immediately that creates
jobs new jobs create shops you've got
construction workers construction
projects being cancelled
left right and in between houston's the
worst city in america right now by the
way dallas is the best we're growing the
fastest
i think i think you i think you're i
absolutely agree with you you are smart
about infrastructure
spending and if i'm mitch mcconnell and
biden says i want to have
i i want i want a trillion dollars i
want a half trillion dollars
for all the band-aids and all the social
programs that need immediate assistance
but
if i'm mcconnell i'm saying i want a
half trillion dollars
for infrastructure spending immediately
so that the republicans can start to say
that they passed
smart stimulus that put people back to
work
and because it's all going to come out
in the wash because it looks like
it looks like the republican lead in the
senate it is also going to be skinnier
after that democratic seat flipped
overnight real quick danielle i see fox
news
is reporting that biden is at 264. it's
been that way for
24 hours that means usa today and fox is
saying two seconds i mean
he won basically saying he won arizona
he was one more state nevada all he knew
whatever
it was nevada yeah it's just nevada
nevada has a difference of eight
thousand right is that the number
eight or so 7 500 something like that
our good friend kai over there brought
up a really good point
and i'm not going to say who he voted
for but what he did say
was that he hopes that if biden wins if
biden wins
he wins by more than 270 meaning he
wants him to get a 300 he doesn't want
it to be like
razor thin for the country meaning he
wants him to win pennsylvania
georgia it's just so it's not a freaking
question again
pennsylvania for all the fraudulent
people out there it's a fraud it's this
it's a that
you said there's been a thousand cases
of voter fraud in the last 40 years
so for all our conspiracy theorists out
there i hope you're listening but
there there's a bigger issue than voter
fraud if he gets pennsylvania and right
now again
pennsylvania vegas is saying 85
probability that he's going to get
pennsylvania
pennsylvania is the one place where
having another
supreme court justice in his in his
corner
could do but before the election see
pennsylvania changed the law to say that
they could
they could count ballots for longer than
they used to
that's different in some states you had
to count them on that day and report
them and that was it
yeah but but there's one place that
trump could take that because three
one two three supreme court justices
said you know what
this could be a violation of the
constitution what the state of
pennsylvania is doing
we could revisit this yes i saw that and
that was that's three supreme court
justices but now there's a fourth
so in theory though then you would still
have a hung court you would still have
four to four what do you think when do
you think we're going to know for a fact
that
the transition from uh trump to biden if
biden were to win
how soon do you think that could happen
i i think that if he wins nevada
and arizona is validated elsewhere
i think he's in because that that extra
16 in in pennsylvania
it it won't make a difference if other
people
call arizona and he gets nevada does
this have any merit here and this is
according to our research here
there are laws in every state that grant
local officials days or even weeks
deadlines vary from state to state to
canvas and certify election results
here's the date
states technically have until december
8th
which is known as safe harbor as a
deadline to fully
certify results there's nothing that
says everything has to be in
on tuesday november 3rd the deadline
quote unquote safe harbor is december
8th
where does that factor again i don't
think that most people calling states
are calling states unless they feel that
they have a comfortable margin
how familiar are you with the 14th
amendment
oh gosh the 14th amendment allows the
president to strip electoral college
votes from states supporting censorship
against voters enables mass arrests of
mayors governors and judges who support
blm dc dirty laundry so that's one thing
that's coming out
in article six section three of us
constitution when the state fails to
hold free and fair elections then the
republican form of government that state
has been compromised interfering or
manipulating
a federal election is a conspiracy
against the constitution and people
executive authority which is a person
united states has been charged with the
faithful execution of all
laws pursued to the constitution and
also the constitution itself that is
caps
because it's critical so so there's
because that's
the angle that giuliani wants to take
around i don't know if you saw juliana's
talk yesterday but that's the fraud
angle
right if they go to fraud angle but you
have to know that he has the supreme
court if he takes that angle
if he takes that angle because there is
a
did you did you hear giuliana's speech
yesterday i did did you hear giuliana's
speech yesterday
he was he was livid
and you know trump's a litigious guy i
don't think we're going to find out the
transition is going to be very soon
i think it's going to take some time i
don't think it's going to be as quickly
as january 20th
it's giuliani can jump in here yes the
leave office that's when the new
president is sworn in is that what it is
21st is inauguration january 20 yeah
giuliani can be as livid as he can the
court has discretion on whether or not
to hear
anything when is giuliani not ever livid
what the court
has said it would reconsider does not
have to do with what giuliani is
bringing up
it has to do with the fact that the
pennsylvania the state of pennsylvania
changed the law to allow for the
counting of the votes for three days
after the election
that's what the supreme court is is
willing
they've they three justices have said
that they're open to revisiting that
every other
fraud type of case that has come before
the supreme court
as well though they're doing wisconsin
because it's less than one percent it
has been no that is that that has
nothing to do with the super supreme
court
that has to do with russia oh no that
has to do with recounts i agree i agree
what i'm saying is but what i'm saying
is that the supreme court has
has pushed every other case
especially those related to fraud
they've pushed them out
and said no we're not hearing the case
so the only one that i know of that
that the supreme court will hear and has
said publicly we would consider this
has to do nothing with fraud yeah so
so and and the the challenge is if they
go
because you know back in 2020 they just
won one state florida because they
didn't want to say this
floor this state uh because you
negotiated it this way that applies to
this state so they're just
they they're suggesting going multiple
states may not help trump
but if it's close he goes one state he
can flip it
yes but if it's two three four states it
may hurt them and back far on them so
it'd be interesting to see what happens
by the way a few different things
business wise
you're watching how people are reacting
how the market react the bazel selling
off three billion dollars of shares of
amazon
you're seeing some of those things what
do you what are you noticing you said
nike letting go of some middle
management how is the economy going to
respond to abiding economy
how's the market going to respond to the
market's up big today and it was up big
yesterday it was
yeah so like meaning they think that
biden's winning and it has not slowed
down the money i think they like the
senate being gridlocked and yeah they're
like the market the market is buying
taxes are not changing is what they're
saying there we go
you had the largest one-day decrease
in the nation's borrowing costs since
february i want to say
so that was the borrowing cost of the
nation bond yields were very
elevated elevated elevated yeah coming
in because of the potential for a blue
wave
and some massive multi-trillion dollar
stimulus package being
you know signed into law by by
valentine's day that was the concern
so you're seeing the market price back
in gridlock
and a much lesser degree of stimulus
that's not going to affect how corporate
america behaves with regards to its
workforce
at all how corporate america is going to
behave with regards to its workforce is
has only to do with the coronavirus
right now and how
everything is up today and how that
affects consumption
dao s p nasdaq the russell 2000 bitcoins
up gold's up disney's up apple's up it's
all up
facebook's up google's up tesla's up
which is actually
norwegian cruise lines which hasn't been
up in like nine months and they just
they just what is that
most important one obviously and they
just gotta say we gotta go on our cruise
after that those guys
right now right now you've got a lot of
um positioning in markets there's a lot
of noise in the markets right now
i think wait until we have it decided
i got three other things before we wrap
up i got a flight to get to and
everybody's text me i know i got a
flight i get i fully get it i'm gonna go
10 more minutes and i'm gonna try to
make my flight
okay so uh uh one is uber
good news california prop 22 uh
winning inside of an independent
contractor so means uber and lyft
drivers will stay as independent
contractors in the state of california
that's very very please talk about that
pat why you feel so
uh oh we've been talking about it for a
while give us your thoughts on why
you're happy that it went that way i'm
very happy because that just means that
the
model of being an independent contractor
is not going to be threatened in the
state of california for
other people i think byron udall when he
was sitting right in danielle's chair he
talked but if you do that you're going
to have to do that to ebay independent
contractors
everybody's you have to turn them to w-2
and it's a phenomenal thing
it's great for the state of california
the other thing is minimum wage in the
state of florida went to 15
by 2026 right and and that
to be honest with you it's a little
concerning to say hey we're going
straight to
15 bucks by 2026 what do you think about
that look it's barely going to keep up
with the cost of living adjustments and
you know we were speaking about this
yesterday that major us corporations
whether you're talking about walmart
or mcdonald's they've already moved
they've already crossed that line
in order to retain it and keep good
employees so
because it's a graduated stair step i'm
not too
terribly concerned about it uh you know
i would be a lot more concerned had we
had a blue wave
and there was discussions of a federal
uh minimum wage being implemented
you know which eventually in the next
one or two years i think that one state
after another we will see it what we saw
in 19 states come in a few years ago all
at once
so i think we're on our way i think
floridians did this
uh in a in it in a decisive way
such that it again is just a dollar a
year
to become competitive with your local
walmart and by the way to be honest with
you like here when i said one of my
accountants every time i think we have
one employee with us that makes less
than 15 bucks okay i think one it's like
13.50 one of our employees and you know
the minimum wage in texas is 7.25 or 7.
it's like so i mean how the hell do you
live off of seven bucks you don't you
don't right you have to be a 16 year old
kid to be able to live off of that
but i think the federal part if they do
that across the country that hurts
places like arkansas that hel heart
south dakota's i mean you can't do 15
out everywhere there are those small
businesses are going to take
florida okay i can see 20 20. you did an
austin
awesome how-to episode of the board
about having a minimum wage yes
a living wage yeah what's your biggest
takeaway with that exactly what i just
said you can't do it across the board
you heard it not if the federal minimum
wage
what is the federal minimum wage is it
725 i think it is 7.25
if they raise federal minimum wage in
the next two to four years to eight
bucks
nine bucks okay whatever if they do
federal to 15
you're not going to feel it we're not
going to feel it but i will tell you
millions oh buddy they're going to feel
it
and all it's going to do if they do that
walmart
and south dakota wins okay right a
target in arkansas wins the small
johnny's little market that's been on
for 73 years goes out of business the
big dogs
can afford they don't understand that
increasing the federal minimum wage
you're putting small business owners out
of business it's not as sexy as it
sounds
doesn't affect california doesn't affect
florida it doesn't affect illinois it
doesn't affect new york
but it does affect the big states in big
cities what's interesting is the
opposite trend right now so if you're a
silicon valley worker
and you've been working in that most
expensive area of the world around san
francisco san jose
and and you decide to go relocate
somewhere because you work at a company
that said you can
work from home indefinitely silicon
valley is decreasing
your salary right now depending on where
you've moved to
so it's interesting that that's how
california companies are behaving
so they get the whole it is there's a
different cost of living
depending on where you live part but do
you think california will see a
republican governor anytime soon oh gosh
i mean i mean it's going to melt off
into the ocean at some point with those
finances
so so that's that's a that's a no i
would assume i would think that would be
okay
what about that post you did on
instagram with those entrepreneurs that
came up with the
drones phenomenal crazy it's phenomenal
let me let me let me do the last one
here before we wrap up let me do the
last one before i wrap up so
it's actually not a gotcha type of a
thing i'm just wondering like you know
joe biden gives a speech okay and you
have to know that a lot of people
who for the longest time have been in
politics are sitting there saying
this freaking guy is going to be the
46th president i'm better than him
i cannot believe this guy's going to be
the president one person in america
i'm wondering how you think she's doing
hillary clinton
how do you think she's doing knowing a
joe biden she has to call him perfect
she's even saltier
are you kidding me are you
wait let me get this straight so you
think i think i think kamala's a vp
kamala b hillary clinton you have to
realize it's like to her it's like that
cannot happen
i'm more qualified how is hillary doing
right now but there's expletives in
between she's the most notorious
sailor potty mouth in the world yeah
she's probably
angry today than she was for how do you
think she's feeling i think there's part
of her that's saying
still like really like dude like i was
so qualified i was so prepared
you know but i think she come to terms
and look people didn't like me all that
much
she corrected her own dnc you know that
she's got to feel good if trump loses
she's got to get she's going to have the
last laugh like we talked about at the
top of the show
democrats came together whether whether
you believe that trump's going to say
dude i became a president you didn't
what are you talking about that ends as
well and she'll say well my husband was
there eight years my uh
yeah my secretary of state for obama for
a year
ambition where on earth do you think her
ego fits into
citing her husband i mean she's like
four years to
you you really can't you know they were
they were both scholars
and she believed she's smart sweetheart
okay let's flip it
let's flip it who did hillary vote for
what do you mean who to hillary of
course what's your favorite so my point
is she wanted right into words
qualifies for what's your point she
watches one of those buttons you pray
you just say president
do you think she's your point you think
she like held her nose and voted for
biden no
she get it she went to the she voted she
filled in her mailing
libertarian campaign alexander joseph
just gave 10 bucks saying they found
nine states with voter fraud and they
found these states have more votes than
registered voters so
look i don't think it's over the 15 by
the way can you double check to see what
vegas says has a change at all is it
still like 15 percent
15 percent they still have 15 trump
having a chance to win let's see did you
check it yeah i just checked it you just
checked the right notes so in the last
90 minutes it has not changed
the chances of trump winning according
to vegas odds is
odds to defeat to defeat trump remain
steady and they are currently
84.9 85 to fifteen
eighty four point nine percent
eighty-five to fifteen that's the number
eighty-five to fifteen last night it was
ninety-ten
that's what it has increased yep just to
put it to put in perspective you know we
know that trump
barely sleeps when he went to bed
um
when trump went to bed this would have
been tuesday night
he was 75 chance likely to win
and he woke up and he was 25 chance
likely to win
talk about a shitty night's sleep but
that that move overnight from
10 15 10 to 15 that
is lingering arizona uncertainty listen
if you're watching this if you think if
you
sold it if you still think trump has a
chance of winning click that subscribe
button
if you think there's no way in the world
trump subscribe to the subscribe button
if you think trump doesn't spam cloud
[ __ ]
over the building so many people hit it
trump doesn't stand a chance to win
click the dislike button no i'm telling
you guys i'll show you what happened
it's probably not going to go up that
much because matter of fact it didn't
even go up at all on the subscribe
button
if you think trump's going to win click
that subscribe button same number it
didn't
the thumbs down went up let's give a
shout out to our
our loyal audience we were hovering
around almost five thousand viewers
today
we didn't even ask people to share it
today we totally forgot 90
you know pat's got to catch a flight
he's got his private jet sitting outside
warming up on the runway and then he's
going to jump out of here
uh but i know that pat appreciate your
is your private jet outside uh as well
danielle
all kinds of fired up okay yeah just
like the one that the road runner uses
thank you for coming down and giving
your perspective we always appreciate
your perspective
good podcast here gang have a wonderful
day enjoy the madness over the weekend
it's a show
we'll see who's going to get elected
take care everybody bye bye bye
you